greets everyone I'm Alana and welcome to
my channel and today I'm going to be
talking about my top games of 2016 I
know it would make a lot more sense to
do a top 5 but I had so much trouble
deciding on which should be the fifth so
four heads and number four is other
watch other watch does an incredible job
of getting a group of very eclectic
heroes that are all incredibly different
they all seem like if you line them up
they wouldn't make any sense existing in
the same game but they do it's also just
incredibly well animated like if you're
playing as Bastion the way that he moves
in the way that the tip of his gun is
kind of flicks while he walks you
actually feel like a machine and in that
character variety I also think that
overwatch is accessible to pretty much
everyone the person who can get a
perfect headshot in overwatch is no more
valuable than someone who is slower and
more thought-out and instead of having
just one definition of skill that is
required for you to be good at overwatch
it gives people the option of which
skill they would like to be good at and
balances those together really well so
that you create a [ __ ] amazing
community of totally different play
styles that all work in the same game
world overwatch is a meticulously
designed game they did a great job
number three is the witness which is a
little bit of a different one for those
who don't know the witnesses in the
simplest homes a puzzle game but I kind
of want to say it is a language game you
walk around beautiful environments you
interact with puzzles but the point is
there is no tutorial the way that you
learn how each different kind of puzzle
can be solved is by the witness teaching
you this language without any text
without any actual instruction you just
figure it out because it gives you an
easy puzzle that goes by this one
language and then a slightly hotter one
I have to draw the line and I have to
group these two colors together and
these colors can't touch each other and
it never tells you that you just have to
one and as you go on the things that
you've wand at the start of the game are
incorporated into puzzles in the later
game and it's really hard to think of
another game that has treated me like I
was smart in the way that the witness
did I think a lot of games treat people
like a dunk oh god like how our battery
is dying number two is
inside inside I think had the best
narrative of 2016 it tells you a story
solely through kind of action and almost
through the ambience in the first couple
of minutes despite there being no
cutscenes no dialogue you feel the
tension you are trying to figure out
whether you're breaking into something
or escaping from something and it does
such a good job of subtly piecing
together this story that even after you
finish it will leave you with really
intriguing questions I think some people
were really disappointed by the ending
and I understand that I was not one of
those people I loved the end of inside
and I loved the range of emotions it
gave me I don't think game has ever
disgusted me so much but delighted me so
much at the same time inside also has
some really creative level design and
some awesome puzzles but I don't want
talk about inside too much because it is
a short game and I don't want to spoil
anything so let's move on to my number
one a lot of you probably already know
what does it is cuz they keep talking
about it on Twitter and I keep talking
about it on podcasts it is dishonored to
Dishonored one did not grab me that much
dishonored to [ __ ] amazing game there
are so many ways to enter every single
building and so many ways to get to
whatever your objective is and so many
obstacles and different ways that you
can approach them that it just feels
like there is no cap on your creativity
there's one level that I go to it's
called the clockwork mention I'm not
going to tell you anything about it if
you haven't already seen it because it's
incredible when you experience for
yourself I played through that level a
couple of times and the first time took
me like four hours until I figured out
just how intricate it is and how
interconnected every piece of that
mention is that you could finish it in
like half an hour my camera battery died
so I'm finishing this on my iPhone I'm
sorry you guys disown it too has thus
modest level design that I think that I
have ever encountered in a video game
will that are really ever there's also
you know tons of abilities that you can
use that you can string together in
amazing ways and I think my appreciation
for Dishonored 2 grew even stronger when
I saw stuff other people were doing on
YouTube and the way they were
approaching the missions that I had just
swallowed my way through because I'm
[ __ ] awful at the game I barely
upgraded my powers and played it
basically I would try to ghost until
someone noticed me and then I would
knock them out and keep playing I don't
like save scumming in stealth games
which is basically why as soon as
someone notices you you reload to save
and I didn't think the game would be as
fun in high chaos which is just like
going out and motoring everyone in a
level but then I saw people do it on
YouTube and I was like holy [ __ ] this
game is just so [ __ ] impressive
there's so many things that I've seen
people do that I didn't even know you
could do in that game and I just feel
like the surprises absolutely never end
and those are my top 4 games of the year
of course you guys will have different
lists totally that stuff that I really
wanted to include but decided not to for
whatever reason I know a lot of people
think uncharted 4 is game of the year
but I really enjoyed uncharted 4 but it
doesn't make the list of me because I
don't even think it's the best Uncharted
game I think uncharted 2 was a better
game overall I feel like uncharted 4 got
a little bit lost at certain parts and I
really got frustrated with thee oh wait
it's moved go here oh wait it's move go
here oh wait it's moved go here that
just kept happening it's felt like it it
dragged on a little towards the end and
those unfortunately the parts that I am
remembering the most because they were
towards the end it's still a great game
but I knew people would specifically
[ __ ] about me not including that one so
I just wanted to say that's specifically
why I didn't include it and that is it
for me today you guys I hope you enjoyed
this video let me know what games made
your list thank you guys so much for
watching I will see y'all next time